if you had a threesome with one female  actor who would have  sydney sweeney yes margot robbie oh  that's exactly like margaret margaret  yeah i love her voice on wolfe wall  street though margot robbie's voice like  daddy  oh there's so many  so brad pitt just like consistently does  it for me  what the one he's the one mark wahlberg  when you had mark wahlberg here and i  didn't see him i wanted to cry i'm  obsessed with mark wahlberg yeah he's  probably like you're a hike shorter i  was taller yeah yeah  never mind not a bad thing ryan gosling  so now you're turning down mark wolver  i'm not turning him down i'm just  changing you don't like to be taller  though you said that i know uh ryan  golfing gosling bleach blonde hair from  barbie doll i want that okay